welcome to this video playing our petal
intercessor under a penny teen your what
now let's do something funky no sorry i
recently tried them Cooper a chick who
pride shake variation with this going to
do that again yeah how do you play here
just 96 actually i don't know i think it
cannot be that bad going from to some
kind of hmm that's early and not I don't
play a dragon here necessarily
I can take and go in five okay well I
can take with the beep on okay so b5
here it looks kind of normal here this
pollution need to gain some time at
least on a move like before it's not so
clear way as night is going so you
really going to a fall down or okay
airplanes anyway so no use in pretending
half considering that i'm considering
alternatives he really goes there which
looks pretty bad but maybe it isn't so
let's think about it for a moment the
night looks almost like it's almost
trapped of course there are the things
happening in the position zone okay I'm
taking and now Bishop here first maybe
edit it i think it makes some sense to
also 3d seven for the night feels it
feels like i have to do that anyway and
they have to cover be six so that 96 is
not happening Wow does he just does he
really want to win that point help
before I would be immensely cheeky but
maybe maybe you can do that
do I want to play a five year I don't
know that looks very slow t 596 look
strange Queen a5 that special p6 say
that sets important losing my queen now
okay come on if you want to take before
not much I can do actually if it takes
before I have the movie should be true
that said that's pretty strong i believe
winning the f3 born think this should be
good the other thing is see far as d5
what i looked at earlier but i think
that this makes some sense specially
considering that f3 porn is kind of the
backbone of his position i still have
that d5 move available with a tempo on
the queen I only hope that I'm not
having my bishop trapped by some City
tactic I guess I always have defiled
like if i take f3 and echo d5 with the
tempo then i will take Bishop takes
before at the end anyway this type of
position is crazy and I tend to not do
well that me because it's just so so
murky I usually don't play any Sicilian
defense we're on my my king is on
opposite sides of the board I really
usually don't do well there I just
spotted that bishop and three days maybe
something on g7 Quincy three or
something wacky but okay I'm taking here
first and then see what happens
don't really have any alternative and
his rook is of course hanging so that's
also i just noticed something like rook
f 1 95 yeah sign that's all that move
it's really really wacky but I wait
Quincy three that's 95 it's not he's not
getting the bishop at our check I just
keep it
white reason yes I had the head thought
ever really thought it worked but it
doesn't only saw that him so that later
okay so let's look at this this line
it's it's somewhat strange looking move
but it's not that bad lettuce black is
somewhat flexible you can still go with
g6e six and so it's not that bad doesn't
doesn't really lead to any a big trouble
for black f 3 i'm not really sure about
f3 I mean it's it it cannot be terribly
bad but it doesn't feel very necessary
you know if why does some going form
some kind of long I mean okay let's say
but should be three kind of stuttering
him if he goes here and I go is six then
he can do this this whole setup that you
did without the move f3 and can maybe go
like g4 g5f for quicker yeah and if I'm
going g6 then f3 is some kind of Dragon
anyway okay this should be three was
played a bit early there are some move
all the issues but I don't know it feels
a little bit more ambitious or something
like that a six I really don't know
what's going on here this is any good to
be 494 there should be five yeah i mean
the computer already gives black a
pretty big advantage maybe the night is
already really in a in a tough spot 97 I
think that's a good move g5 was also an
e5 I mean had to play that anyway I
think and now there should be two and
now the computer wants to go F form
giving at the exchange with black being
slightly ahead
this this yeah I know it's it's a
problem he cannot really do what he did
and as I mentioned after this I have the
move d 5 which lets me take their or
with the bishop and then black is better
in the center and then still this this
wacky night I mean stockbridge is pretty
clear about this mean minus 1.5 so black
is winning action actually with with
we're back computer standards but the
position is so lucky that anything can
happen in a blitz game and yeah he saw
that that tactic but she didn't it
didn't work out I'm just protecting the
bishop here no it's not really
mechanically try to get it back I think
I think I can while taking it is
probably not a great idea this is
actually the comp roof it's pretty
strong yeah they look has no squares
really no good ones let its interest
material down and those two don't do
anything okay thanks for watching